لم تكن الصوره في اليمن قاتمه كما هي عليه
اليوم خاصه في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
الحكومه الشرعيه اليمنيه والمقاومه
الشعبيه المسانده لها الى اين يمضي بنا
ركب التحالف العربي يتساءل الناس بعد
عامين واكثر من انطلاق عاصفه الحزم واعاده
الامل بقياده المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وقد اثار هذا السؤال وهذه المخاوف بشكل
جدي ما يراه اليمنيون من ازمه خليجيه بين
مكونات رئيسيه في التحالف العربي اقتضت
هذه الخلافات بالضروره ان تجر رجل الحكومه
اليمنيه لفعل ما فعلته الدول الثلاث
الامارات والسعوديه والبحرين فاصدر بيانا
لقطع العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع قطر
المشاركه بفاعليه في دعم تحالف الشرعيه
قبل اعلان السعوديه انهاء مهمه قطر في
التحالف وعوده قواتها من الحد الجنوبي في
الحدود السعوديه اليمنيه ولان كانت
الخلافات صادمه ليمنيين كانوا ينتظرون ان
يحسم التحالف امره في استعاده شرعيتهم
ودولتهم التي انقلب عليها الحوثيون
والرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح فقد
فتحت الباب واسعا على مناقشه دور التحالف
في اليمن منذ بدئه في ال 26 من مارس عام
2015 بدا واضحا ان التحالف الذي تقوده
الرياض وابو ظبي لم تكن لديه خطه واضحه
لهذه المهمه الصعبه في بلد صعب على كل
المستويات الجغرافيه والسياسيه والعسكريه
والاجتماعيه ولم يعد سرا على احد ان
الدولتين اللتين احتفظت بقياده هذا الملف
متباينان في الرؤيه والتوجه مما افشل
عمليات الحسم في المناطق التي كان يفترض
ان تحسم عسكريا بسرعه لصالح المقاومه
والجيش مثل تعز التي ظل عشرات الالاف من
ابنائها يدفعون الثمن بسبب رفض ابو ظبي
التقدم لحسمها بعد استعاده عدن منتصف عام
2015 بحجه انها الكتله الصلبه لحزب
الاصلاح اليمني الاخوان المس المسلمون اما
في الجنوب فقد انفجر في وجه اليمنيين ملف
الانفصال الذي لم يكن خافيا ان ابو ظبي
ترعاه وتهيئ له من خلال سيطرتها على
محافظه الجنوب عقب استعادتها من ميليشيات
الحوث
وصالح شكلت ابو ظبي قوات الحزام الامني في
عدن بقوام 12 الف مقاتل واوكل تها لشخصيه
سلفيه مقربه منها هو هاني بن بريك يعمل
خارج السلطه الشرعيه وفي حضرموت استحدثت
الويه عسكريه تحت مسمى النخبه الحضرميه
تعمل تحت اشرافها وتمولها وشجعت المجلس
الانفصالي الذي اعلنه من عدن عيدروس
الزبيدي محافظ عدن المقال ونائبه هاني بن
بوريك بعد ان دفعتهما لرفض قرارات الرئيس
اليمني عبد الربو منصور هادي ووجهت الكثير
من الاتهامات لهادي وحكومته لاضعاف
والسيطره على المشهد
اليمني وما اثار الاستغراب منذ اطلاق
السعوديه تحالف دعم الشرعيه في ال
والت المق لئه رم مشاركه الحرس الجمهوري
الذي كان يقوده في الحرب خاصه على الحدود
السعوديه واطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه مدنها
واخر تصريحاته من ابو ظبي دعوته لاعضاء
حزب المؤتمر بالتوحد لمواجهه ما وصفه
بالعدوان صوره اخرى لا تقل غرابه تتمثل في
السعي لبناء تشكيلات مسلحه خارج سيطره
الدوله في المناطق التي تقع تحت قبضه ابو
ظبي وبناء معتقلات وسجون سريه لمعاقبه
المعارضين لها في شكل من اشكال استدعاء
التنظيمات المتطرفه والارهابيه وزعزع
الاستقرار في مناطق وجود الحكومه ما الذي
تحقق وما الذي لم يتحقق اذا نظره سريعه
لواقع الحال منذ انطلاق عاصفه الحزم في
اليمن تشير الى خيبه امل كبيره فالنتائج
حكومه ضعيفه وغير قادره على بط سيطرتها
وفوضى في المنا المساعده من يد
الانقلابيين كمؤشر على الفشل وانقسام داخل
جسد التحالف العربي المساند للشرعيه
وبينهما غياب رؤيه حول كيفيه استكمال
المهمه التي طالما صفق لها اليمنيون
المعارضون للانقلاب والذين يدفعون ثمنها
تشر وموتا ومرضا
وانكسارا تلك النتائج فكيف كانت المقدمات